yeah yeah
yeah thank you thank
you thank
you I feel so good it's Friday so you
know what that means let's welcome
tonight's guests she runs bikes and
swims anything to avoid the cops host of
Kennedy Saves the World podcast
Kennedy he the funniest thing to come
out of New Jersey since Chris Christie's
diet coach actor and comedian Vince
August as a former Miss Florida Citrus
she never blames the
juice former State Department
spokeswoman and founder of Polaris ass
security Morgan Ortegas play the
juice and he's on the naughty list for
eating Santa's reindeer New York Times
best-selling author comedian and former
NWA world champion
Tyrant yes all right now before we get
to some new stories let's do
this Greg's leftovers yeah huh that's
right it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck we'll send Joe Mackie to
a strip club and have lizo give him a
tap
dance tap dance
no you're right tap dance there you go
all right first up according to a new
study humans may be fueling global
warming by breathing in response one
highlevel Washington official said well
I guess that means I'm off the
[Laughter]
hook this week a Delaware man was
arrested for drunk driving after
crashing his car into President Biden's
motorcade the first thing Joe did was
ask the Secret Service if the president
was
okay luckily after the accident uh the
president regained
unconsciousness that is
funny so no no no no I I don't need to
fish for your
applause Jesse mlet was spotted in
public this week reading Matthew Perry's
addiction Memoir Smet is now planning
his own Memoir titled Matthew Perry
attacked me
oh
[Laughter]
Jesus oh didn't think I could get a joke
out of that did you the new Aquaman
movie opens in theaters today customers
are told not to eat a half hour before
watching
it wow wow wow
wowz on the phone yes turns that was
just that that was like knows it's 20
minutes great first
laughter the Detroit Pistons have now
lost 25 straight basketball games what's
a straight basketball game asks the
[Laughter]
WNBA I don't know what that means a new
dating study revealed the number one
turnoff for straight women is men who
identify as Maga
Republicans and the number one turn off
for straight men p
is that is correct every year yes
researchers say Barbie lacks diversity
for example there are no visibly
disabled Barbies oh yeah says Ken I was
born without a
penis I mean that's a disability when
you think about it scientists in Alaska
claim they had a 20-minute conversation
with a whale apparently its first words
were up next on The
[Applause]
View commuters in the California Bay
Area have been puzzled for months over a
lingering rotting corpse smell on
certain trains but Transit officials say
it's nothing to be concerned about now
that they've pinpointed the
source
scientists say you should sleep naked
even when it's cold out as it's better
for your body you know who also says you
should sleep naked your neighbor
Frank
Jesus I have a neighbor named Frank
wow Megan rapino calls playing on the US
soccer women's soccer team the worst job
in the world
I know that's news to Brian kill's
intern why NASA streamed a video of a
cat back to Earth from nearly 19 million
miles away it's part of a project to
develop a lunar rover that can watch you
take
a that's my
favorite cuz that's what cats
do video of a Democrat Aid was posted
online of him having gay sex in one of
the hos capitals meeting rooms it's the
first time someone on Capitol Hill
willingly gave up their
seat a hospital workers rant went viral
after she received a baked potato as her
Christmas bonus it's a Christmas miracle
said one
[Laughter]
man is that really yeah and finally this
week a baby elephant was born at Walt
Disney World weighing in at 218 lbs
beating the previous
record now to the news The Washington
Post strains to blame Trump for injured
brains wo just published another
ridiculous article desperately trying to
link Trump to something evil this time
violence and injuries in youth football
which is ironic because if anyone is on
steroids it's their owner Jeff
Bezos wo suggests Trump's to blame for
your kids football injury because of the
politic politicalization of the
concussion crisis and how it's forging
deeper divisions between those who
support youth foot football and those
who don't I got to say if they can pull
that out of their ass they should really
be drug
mules says one lib Egghead quote there
seems to be a very disturbing
possibility that who your dad voted for
could influence your risk for a very
serious ailment or
injury yeah that's rich suddenly
Liberals are worried about brain
damage wo also discovered that students
in states that went for Trump in 2020
played High School football at higher
rates than in states that voted for Joe
Biden the point being I guess if a high
school football player's father voted
for Trump he's more likely to get hurt
cuz conservative parents don't give a
crap about their children's safety yeah
remind me to check back on that in a few
years when those caring Liberals are
confronted by sons they neutered with
chemical surgery and repeat viewings of
the Gilmore
Girls but I get the point vote for Biden
your kid won't get a football injury
yeah but he might be stabbed by a twice
deported murderer or forced to take a
vaccine that explodes your heart so in
conclusion conservative families were
more likely to have sons who play tackle
football which means liberal families
were more likely to have sons on girls
swim
teams after all your son's place isn't
on the grd iron it's in the girl's
locker room where he's tucking more than
just a
football yeah that's disgusting I know
so Kennedy this is like this is it's not
just an example of going after Trump
it's a it's suggesting that by you
supporting Trump you're complicit in
even harming your family yeah but it
also states that we have all agreed that
football is horrible and you will get
injured and you will you will be
concussed and therefore it's an awful
game because we the liberal Elite have
decided that and that's not necessarily
the case there are a lot of kids who
play football because they love the
sport they hope to go on to college you
can make money playing College in
football now like we've never had so
much excitement about the transfer
portal and because of the nil and the
big decision surrounding that kids might
actually make money sooner than if they
go pro but they're also they're
infantilizing black and Latino kids who
want to go play football like oh can you
believe it now they're there are more
Hispanic kids than ever playing football
it's like well good for them maybe their
parents did what Serena and Venus's dad
did went oh wait where are the guys
making all the money oh football I'm
going to go ahead and have my son start
that in high school and maybe that will
lead to a career and some money down the
road MH good point Vince I think you
could do if you were a fair media you
could apply the same logic to any a
Biden supporter or a Biden voter you're
more likely you know to abort a baby
you're more likely to euthanize a
relative you're more likely to burn down
a business but but that's the thing
about this to see and and really Kennedy
set it up it's football is American it's
part of our American fiber and right now
anything that's American let's trash it
because that's what we want to do we
want to break everything down I mean
Super Bowl Sunday is Winter's Fourth of
July and the other thing that Kenny
brought up and the article brings up is
that it talks about disadvantaged kids
gravitating towards football well if
disadvantaged kids are gravitating
towards Trump who is a country club guy
guy and all of the rich people are
gravitating towards Democrats then isn't
that really the problem then maybe
Democrats instead of screaming at the
problem should be trying to fix the
problem and try to figure out why aren't
these disadvantaged kids looking at us
and they're looking like a at a guy like
Donald Trump yeah so fix your problem
don't scream at your problem exactly you
know uh Morgan uh it seems to me that it
it's uh it's just another example of
what's going to happen for the next year
anything related to Trump is going to be
deemed destructive like you for example
example that's true I was the
spokesperson it's like it still gets to
me I mean it's been since 2015 and the
extent that he still lives rentree and
people's heads you know like it this is
an important article right because there
are concussions in football but to think
at the Washington Post they sat around
and thought I have a great angle to
concussions with kids Trump right like
who I live in Nashville and like people
are doing their thing they're not
sitting around obsessively talking about
Joe Biden every time you have dinner but
I do have a theory on this too sort of
similar to what you guys were saying I I
think that liberals don't like uh they
don't like to Define genders right they
don't like things that are male or
things that are that are female
everything is fluid according to them
and so football is like very I mean I'm
not the resident football expert at Fox
News but it's very machismo it's very
male it's it's very type and um but what
I am expert on is you said uh beauty
pageants because I was Miss Florida
citus and so even something like that
very feminine like The Stereotype so
anything that fits a stereotype of male
or female to them is bad and anything
bad must be Trump's fault that's a
really good point this could just be
about gender what say you Tyrus you
played a lot of ball yeah you know what
he did you know yeah you know what oh I
don't know when it was was it the 50s
when they stopped allowing you to punch
people in the face yes 1953 I think we
need to bring that
back
applauding violence this is my kind of
audience yeah it's my my audience too
thanks for coming St Nick
um this is the echo chamber M cuz nobody
whose kids plays any competitive Sports
gives a about what they were talking
about yeah true because if you play
baseball you can get hit in the head
with the ball right if you walk fast to
the kitchen on a Saturday morning with
sleep in your eye you could fall and
bust your nose open
this is the bulldozer parents these are
the kids that want to raise their sons
to PE sitting down so they can sit they
wait what's wrong with that you did it
for medical purposes that's true that's
true you lost the lawsuit trying to get
toilets dropped three feet to the floor
I get it we even got you a little
toddler foot thing for you I know The
Squatty Potty but we wanted him to feel
like a big man so we said listen I told
him all the tough guys sit down when
they pee it's a new thing just don't
tell any body I told you but the the
point is is that they say these things
because they're they can't fathom seeing
more trump-like men coming into this
world guys who are willing to take risks
get beat up say the wrong thing be men
it's anti-men we went through the whole
thing where they want to steal our women
away we had the Devon mules and Woman
face and now it's oh my God if you don't
do something to stop these boys from
playing sports that keep them out of
jail keep them they learn things like
discipline respect and even if it
doesn't lead to a career in football it
keeps them in school gives them
opportunities for college helps them to
understand what A Hard Day's Work is
structure there's nothing tougher in the
summertime than having 45 lbs of plastic
on with a old guy blowing a whistle
telling you two more gassers and gassers
is not hurting the environment it's when
you run up and down 100 yards back back
and forth it builds character it builds
also guys going into the military from
there so they're against everything it
is the very fabric of what it is to be
an American man so on behalf of all of
us whatever call your local congressman
and let's reinstate the punch in the
face and when I was a kid everything
gave us concussions riding bikes playing
in Parks parents everything can C us
yeah that's true you weren't best
friends unless you concussed each other
that's how it work you can't spell
concuss without
us I thought you were going to say us I
was too but then I just went us which
makes you ass yes hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else